skyler hicks has died she was 23. what's
your name and how old are you my name is
scala hicks i'm 14 years old skylar is
known for wowing the america's got
talent judges back in 2013
[Music]
skylar was found dead on monday in south
carolina the pickens county sheriff's
office confirmed the news to et
in a statement the office says skyler's
death is being investigated as an
accidental overdose in a while quote
drugs and paraphernalia were found on
the scene it's still unclear what
triggered the suspected overdose the
coroner's office has requested a
toxicology report and the investigation
into skyler's death is ongoing
[Music]
in skyler's appearance on agt she played
an original song and opened up about the
loss of her father i started playing
after my dad passed away
a few years ago
he made some bad decisions and
i hadn't seen him in
a few years
i think that you are a beautiful girl
and i'm thankful that you shared your
story with all of us it's a very hard
story i'm sure for you to tell everyone
and i feel that you won all of our
hearts thank you
in the years since skyler often shared
her talent on instagram seen here
singing a cover of shallow from a star
is born
[Music]
as well as pop hits from christina perry
and katy perry
[Music]
cause baby
[Music]
wow
[Music]